as you wake up in the West we are
following breaking news right now a
deadly apparent terror attack in France
ended just moments ago officials say
security forces killed the attacker in a
raid earlier police say the attacker
killed at least three people he was
holed up inside a supermarket in a
standoff with police he reportedly
claimed a connection to Isis the
dramatic events unfolded in the small
city of TREB in southern France
Elizabeth Palmer is in London following
the breaking developments Elizabeth good
morning good morning yes the police have
finally ended what had become a standoff
that had lasted several hours but they
now tell us that the suspects violent
spree began quite early this morning in
a different place altogether he
apparently shot a victim in the head in
the city of caucus on and then opened
fire on four police officers returning
from a morning jog but he got away then
he sped to a suburban supermarket and
there he took shoppers hostage the
French media say the suspect is a man in
his 30s with Moroccan roots and he was
already known to the police for links to
extremism witnesses say that at the
supermarket he shouted I am a soldier of
the Islamic state and in fact some
French media are saying he demanded that
Salah Abdeslam be freed from jail you
may remember he was one of the only
surviving terrorists after the battlin
nightclub attack in 2015 at the
supermarket where the hostages were
being held a French military officer
volunteered to go in if the gunmen would
let the hostages go he did that some of
them were injured and two of them as you
mentioned were killed and as we now know
the gunman is is dead - okay oh yes very
sorry for the loss of life but glad that
is over thank you very much Elizabeth
Palmer reporting from London